It's a big deal, so I want everyone to consult with me I
see, the three different uniforms in my house look good
Hmm, why are you following Hino-san again
?  I don't have one, but I
'm a good
person, so I've decided to use this guy as a role model for females.
Well, try Hina-san's eyes as a test You
've been drunk for a while
Come on, come on,
why are you familiar with that kind of person
?
]
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ahh